The answer is 52.
Referring back to
the order of operations,
we should perform operations
inside parentheses first.
This expression doesn't
have any parentheses so
we can move on to simplifying exponents.
Our exponent here is 6 squared,
which is 36.
Our new expression then becomes
20 divided by 5 times 4 plus 36.
Next, we should multiply and
divide from left to right.
So that means dividing
20 by 5 which is 4.
Again, let's rewrite our expression
which now is 4 x 4 + 36.
We're still working on multiplication
and division from left to right.
So, next we multiply 4 by 4 to get 16.
Now, our expression is 16
+ 36 which gives us 52.
Don't worry if you didn't
get this right away,
there are a lot of rules to remember.
The good news is that with
just a little bit of practice,
the order of operations
starts to feel automatic.
Let's try another.